but we begin this half-hour with more
fallout from the sexual assault
allegations against Hollywood film
producer Harvey Weinstein another board
member has resigned from the company
Weinstein founded and artists and
studios are pulling the plug on projects
brokered with the Weinstein Company this
as Weinstein prepares for a symbolic
knockout blow the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences is holding an
emergency meeting today to consider
whether it should suspend or end
Weinstein's membership don't need a
copal is here with the latest only good
morning good morning if Weinstein is
suspended or expelled he would no longer
be able to vote for nominees or winners
for the Academy Awards he's already been
suspended by the British Film Academy
and now more celebrities are speaking
out against him on Friday members of the
National Organization for Women demanded
Manhattan district attorney Cyrus Vance
jr. prosecute Harvey Weinstein now New
York President Sonja asorio why did they
open in an investigation to see if they
could find more victims because we know
now that they're clearly out there in
2015 Weinstein was recorded admitting to
groping Italian model amber about Alana
Gutierrez da Vance said his office
decided not to move forward with the
case against Weinstein because it was
not going to be provable first of all my
my hands are shaking
on Friday actress and former model Angie
Everhart told TMZ about a disturbing
encounter with Weinstein over a decade
ago she says while she was sleeping on a
boat at the Cannes Film Festival
Weinstein broke into her room and
masturbated in front of her you said
that he told you not to tell anybody and
you told everybody so you told people on
the boat when right after it happened I
told people on the boat I told people at
the dinner I was at and everybody was
like oh that's just Harvey the chorus of
Hollywood heavy hitters condemning
Weinstein has grown louder in a
Hollywood Reporter roundtable discussion
about Weinstein actor Seth Rogen said he
only worked with Weinstein once but that
was enough for him I remember one of the
first stories you heard about him
involved inappropriate sexual misconduct
you know and I think that people I know
the people would say to me when I would
refuse to work with him you know he's
old school it's stuff like that and and
there is kind of like wink and an
acceptance of that type of behavior
producer Amy Pascal I think that the
women who stood up have to be applauded
because that's really really hard to do
when nobody wants to stand up and the
silence is deafening and I think that
that's the part that we're responsible
for Harvey Weinstein has denied
allegations of rape and all the
relationships he says are consensual on
Friday his brother Bob Weinstein denied
reports that the company was exploring a
sale or a shutdown saying business is
going to continue as usual Weinstein
himself plans to fight dismissal from
his company reportedly and if you can
wrap your mind around this apparently
his contract may have allowed for sexual
harassment hoods are clause in there
that yeah there it's going to be a lot
of examination about what the company
knew and how much it indeed know all
right Tony to cope well thanks so much